if by this point you're a little overwhelmed by
wonky economic language never fear I'm joined by
Economist and former Market Trader Gary Stevenson
to make it all make sense Gary thank you so much
for coming back on the show first of all um from
first principles or what is a Government Bond
okay so the first thing to understand is when
the government borrows money it borrows money
from people from things like Pension funds
from wealthy individuals and when you lend
money to the government you get a Government
Bond and basically that that's tradable so I
can lend money to the government and then sell
the Government Bond and then somebody else will
be owed the money so essentially it's a tradable
IOU from the government so why has there been this
movement in the market where the value of British
government bonds has dramatically decreased
it's completely a response to the the
announcement from the government basically so
if you look at what the government has
done you know in the last three years
there's been a massive massive
increase in government debt
um but that was a one-up emergency because of Kobe
and now suddenly out of nowhere the government has
decided that they're going to do this bonfire on
taxes of the riches you know um Traders look at
that and they basically think okay well if you're
not going to tax the rich people who have all the
world you're not going to be able to to pay the
debt back and that basically leads to sort of
essentially the reason governments can take
large debts is because the economy grows and
because there's inflation when inflation happens
it devalues the debt makes it easy to pay back
Traders and economists don't believe this is
going to have any growth so they're saying really
the government is going to have to do one of two
things which is not pay the debt back or create
inflation and they sell the pound because there's
going to be inflation pounds are worth less that
means there will be inflation because when the
pound collapse in Imports become more expensive
which means the Central Bank who has a job to
control inflation will then have to raise rates
and markets are expecting a massive increase in
interest rates so Traders they look at the central
bank and they think well these guys are going
to raise rates massively so why am I going to
hold government bonds that give me three percent
when the central bank is expected now to raise
rates to five six or even seven percent it seems
like the big event that sort of forced the bank
of England to make this dramatic intervention um
was the potential for a run Dynamic on Pension
funds so what would a run Dynamic on Pension
funds be why would that be caused by a loss of
value in government bonds okay so let's explain
this from Basics okay so obviously lots of people
have money in a pension and a big investment
that a lot of Pension funds do is to buy
government wants now some Pension funds in order
to sort of boost their buck and get a little bit
more bang for their money they borrow money to
buy even more government bonds so that way you
can borrow cheaply you buy more government
bonds you can get a little bit extra return
um now in the last especially in the last
month but in the whole of the last year because
Interest Bank of England
interest rates have been rising
the value of bonds have been steadily falling
because now interest rates have been nearly zero
for the last 10 15 years that means that a lot
of these bonds have very very low interest rates
now if the central bank is going to start paying
three four five six percent on cash you don't want
to be holding a zero interest Government Bond so
Traders have been selling these government bonds
Pension funds who have borrowed money to buy
loads of government bonds and suddenly in a
situation where you've borrowed a million quid
you've bought a million quid of government bonds
and those bonds are only worth 900 800 000
pounds now so the people who lent the money
are turning around to them and saying okay well
we need you to front up some more money because
we don't we don't trust you anymore because
the assets you hold are not worth enough
well then that means the Pension funds to pay
that money have to sell the bonds which drives the
bond price down even further and you can get this
vicious spiral where institutions such as Pension
funds continue you have to sell the asset in
order to pay back the debt which drives the price
further and further down and and the price keeps
falling and these institutions can go bankrupt
so they called that the Doom Loop don't they
so the value is falling so they have to sell
it to convert it to cash that makes the
value fall even more so then they have
to they need to sell it more and then and the
bank of England's intervention was to try and
stop this Doom Loop happening so the bank of
England they have the power to print lots of
money and they've intervened they've said look if
no one wants to buy these bonds so the the price
is falling what we're going to do is we're
going to buy loads of them that will push up
demand that will push up the price to a point
where these Pension funds aren't in in danger
um makes sense you know if if you're the one
institution that can very easily print money and
intervene in the market I can see why they've done
it is is there a problem here why should we or
should we be worried that the bank of England has
printed a load of money to buy government bonds
I mean this goes back to the thing I've been
saying a lot whenever I've done media in the
last couple of years right which is whenever the
bank of England prints a ton of money especially
when it's a lot of money and whenever the
government gives out a lot of money you need to
be asking where that money is going to end up so
essentially what we have here is a situation where
the government has slashed taxes on rich people
this is after the three years which have seen the
biggest and fastest ever increase in millionaire
and billionaire wealth in the country okay
the government has now slashed taxes on them
the market has said well we think that's that
makes you financially unsustainable so we're
basically going to pull a plug on you and the
bank of England is basically coming in and funding
it so now you have a situation where the bank of
England is essentially funding a massive cash
transfer from the government to the rich on the
back of the biggest ever cash transfer we've ever
seen from the government to the rich and I want
to put some numbers on this you know because I
think it's amazing I don't think people realize
you know if you were to tax the wealthy enough
now to make them as rich as they were before
covert started you could give every single
adult in the country 12 000 pounds and that
is before the energy stimulus which is another
150 billion pounds to the energy companies and
before the massive tax cuts for millionaires
so what you're seeing here is a continuation
of a systemic issue where the government
and the Central Bank together are pumping
hundreds of billions of pounds to the rich and
the consequence for Ordinary People is that
prices go up and inflation goes up and ordinary
people stand the living decreases you know you
cannot expect to see the fastest ever increase
in inequality in the history of the country and
not see living standards for ordinary people fall
so I really want people to push back against this
and I want your thoughts on the IMF so you
know historically when the IMF have come up on
Navara media it'll be to critique them they're
normally you know thought of as an institution
that enforces free market policies on countries
what they normally want to do is cut spending and
IMF programs normally dramatically increase um
inequality especially in in debtor countries so
you might think of Argentina or or Greece or many
countries in in Africa and Asia over the years
why are they suddenly concerned about inequality
why have the IMF released a statement which says
we've got a problem with what quasi quateng has
announced because it will increase inequality
plainly and simply because people are
looking at what the government is doing
now and thinking that is completely insane
it is completely unsustainable you cannot run
massive deficits permanently it's and you know
normally when you see countries try and do this
we're on really big deficits for a long term it's
because of some sort of external disaster or some
sort of really serious situation which requires
an immediate stimulus you know for example covid
now you've got a government that's trying to do
this purely in the service of given an absolute
ton of money to millionaires I mean I'm talking
to traders in the city and the biggest question
here is is what do they think they are doing and
you know we're torn between working out are they
crazy or are they stupid and the IMF is thinking
that you know I've been in markets for a long
time I've never seen anything like this I've never
seen anybody tear their countries finances apart
for something as ridiculous as a massive injection
of cash to the richest people in the country I've
never seen anybody do it and and it's not just me
it's me the IMF it's everybody in the markets just
looking at these guys and asking them what what
are they trying to do it's crazy and what should
happen now I mean I've said the Prime Minister
the chancellor uh you know nowhere to be seen
they they seem to be a bit flummoxed it seems
like they're kind of rabbits in headlights they
didn't realize that their announcement on Friday
would cause such a dramatic reaction I mean what
what could they do to stabilize the markets or
are they just gonna you know keep quiet and hope
the bank of England sort of does the hard work
for them okay something has to give here and
the reason that something has to give is because
in the last week we've seen a massive increase
in interest rates and that is going to cause
an enormous increase in the interest rates of
mortgages okay so you know mortgages in the last
years have been pretty low you know people are
getting mortgages one and a half two percent in
the next couple of years if if nothing is done to
to deal with this mortgage rates are going to go
up to six seven eight percent it's just completely
unsustainable given the level of house prices and
the size of people's mortgages especially young
people who have bought recently who have very
large mortgages there's no way they can afford
these on top of the increasing Energy prices
the increase in food prices this is literally
going to be another this could be in many cases an
extra one thousand fifteen hundred pounds a month
people don't have that so something has the given
it's very difficult to understand what because
if the government is going to do this and interest
rates will be high like that it's as simple as
that and it's politically unsustainable so either
the government has to back down which you know
they're stubbornly saying they won't but I think
it's quite possible in the end they may be forced
to or they need to force the central bank to
massively support them to keep interest rates low
despite the fact that inflation is probably going
to be very high so in that case what your problem
is is another big increase in inflation a collapse
in the pound so there's no good options here other
than the government backing down and you know we
need to do whatever we can to try and force them
to do that so something's got to give you're in
agreement with the IMF everything's getting very
strange all very topsy-turvy Gary thank you so
much um for your Insight today we'll get you back
on soon I'm sure and everyone in our audience
you can check out Gary's YouTube channel which
we've linked to in the description box below lots
of great explainers a very complicated economics